Learning by correcting mistakes is a fundamental process of human learning.
In fact, it may closely resemble the way you and
I learn and practice. In our lives, we rarely are passive learners.
Most of the time we're active participants in the learning process. Even in
a difficult setting like this, you're not just listening to what I'm saying.
Instead, you're using your knowledge and reasoning, to make sense of what I'm
saying. You generate expectations. Sometimes those expectations may be violated.
When they're violated, we generate explanations for
them. We try to figure out, what was in error, in your knowledge and reasoning.
This, is learning by correcting mistakes. Notice, that you think about your own
thinking, a step towards meta-reasoning, which is our next lesson.